hello everyone and welcome to the to
another game from the penultimate round
of the 2019 Greinke chess classic it's
Gehrig Mayer versus a former watches
championship challenger Fabiana Caruana
and there are there were a couple of
games to choose from I decided to choose
this one and well for two reasons one of
them being that Khurana is the winner of
the grantee chess classic 2018 and he's
still trying to catch up to Magnus and
the other one we will disclose after I
show you the game as that's the the more
important one we do have some nice
footage so let's check it out we have
some nice footage of Georg Meyer here so
let's enjoy that for a moment nice close
up by the Greinke chess classic video
team so very nice and also a nice poster
of Fabiana Khurana there you have it
just you know enjoying the position no
no no fruits or booze this time but you
know not every footage is made to be for
is meant to be perfect so without
further ado let's check out the game
Meyer has the white pieces and he opens
with E 4 we have C 5 the Sicilian
defense by Caruana
Knight f3 Knight to c6 and now Bishop to
b5 the Rosalie management Dean of
variation
Najma Dean of attack g6 and now Bishop
captures D captures d3 and Bishop to g7
this is the standard idea
we have h3 by Meier Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 and here we do have a couple of
games in the database that have reached
this position there the main move is
Bishop to d7 but here karana goes for
Knight to d7 in it's a new move already
on move 7 is that he wants to go
Knight to a fate push key 5 and then go
night Stewie 6 the gained further
control of the f4 square and then push
f5 f4
so that's basically the plan for this
variation with the early night maneuver
we have Bishop to e3 by Meier and now
comes C 5 going forward with the plan
Queen to d2 mara wants to exchange the
dark square Bishop seer and now h6 and
now it's okay it might be a weird move
you prevent the Bishop h6 idea but again
you're unable to castle because then the
H upon would be under attack after the
rook moves but karana has everything
figured out as you'll see in the game we
have a 3 B 6 by karana and now before
just attacking that flank and here is
the here comes kuranes idea
we have Knights to f8 a nice pawn
sacrifice the other way to go about this
is to simply push f5 because b4 doesn't
threaten anything after F 5 F 4 is a
threat of winning the best shot but
caranas idea is different and I feel
that well I think he came prepared with
this line Knight to a fate a nice pawn
sacrifice be captures on c5 and now
Knight the e6 now grabbing excellent
control of the F 4 square F 5 F 4 is the
idea so Meier grabs the pawn it captures
some b6 we have 8 captors and b6 and now
you have to do something about this so
Queen to c1 Mr Freeze the D 2 square for
his Bishop we have F 5 by Caruana and
now a 4 F for Bishop to b2 as now the D
2 square has been vacated and now
finally castles by Caruana
this was the idea f4 has been played and
now there there is no danger of Bishop
captures on h6 we have Queen to be 2
putting pressure on the b6 pawn and now
Knights to d4 nice to eat you with a
triple attack against the night here and
now Knight Capra's on f3 g captures on
f3 and now you can see that my arse king
isn't really castling queenside you're
not gonna Castle queenside King side as
it's all messed up so what you will do
is you will probably move the knight
move the King up so to connect rooks and
use the semi open G file for your maybe
an attack against the black king so
Bishop to e6 developing the bishop here
and now comes look to be 1 threatening
to win the pawn here and now comes Luke
to a6 a bit of a passive Mumbai Caruana
as the rook isn't very active on a6 but
it gets the job done there's no way to
further continue the attack against the
b6 pawn
we have Bush up to c3 already with a
nice threat Meier is threatening Knight
captures on f4 which would win the
bishop on g7 and also just Bishop
captures on e5 is a threat so Queens to
c7 by Khurana takes care of both of them
defends the pawn and
also the queen guards the bishop so
Knight f4 doesn't really do anything and
okay for the moment
sorry about that for the moment the rook
is guarding the f4 square but it's a
it's a general idea and now comes rook
to g1 just threatening the g6 pawn with
King to h7 and now comes h4 we have rook
to b8 and here comes Luke to a one as
now that the beasts exponents defended
twice amar was threatening to capture
the a for pawn so here rook to a 1 sorry
Corona was threatening and now c5 here
Corona wants to at some point push c4
and bust open the center and start an
attack against the white king with King
to d2 and now comes looked to d8 and
believe it or not this rook to d8 is a
mistake and Corona really allowed a lot
of activity in this position which is
the other reason I'm showing this game
but we are going to return to this
position after we check out the game
here Mar went rogue cheated b1 he wants
to counter this rook and maybe remover
the king over to the Kings side and now
comes rush of the h3 maybe with ideas of
g2 and capturing the f3 pawn we have
Queen to b5 attacking the rook and now
rook the a8 occur on a double Sunday
file
puts more pressure on the a4 pawn and
now Margo's back rook the g1 and now
comes Queen to d6 a very nice move as it
really protects everything here protects
even the g6 pawn which you know might be
important Queen to beat you now again
with threats of Knight captures on f4
now there's no look on the F file so
captures and the Bishop captures here is
the threat so just look to a7 defending
the bishop here we have rook a to b 1
hoping for rook captures and Queen
captures and b6 and now Queen to f6
Khurana
isn't interested in this trade he goes
for the h4 pawn but first we have a 5 by
Meier and now Bashar back to d7 a
capture son b6 rook to b7 blocking and
preparing to capture our next turn and
only now h5 just hoping to capture here
and bust open the King side but Khurana
closes it with the g5 rook to a-1 now
comes Luke a capture some bees
and now Quinta a three with ideas of
Queen to a8 Mara would very much like to
infiltrate the Queen side but also Queen
captures on c5 is the idea
Queen to d6 just defending and now comes
Knight the c1
he knows that c4 is coming you do want
to defend the d3 pawn so tonight from c1
defense d3 also maybe you could play
Knight b3 at some point but as long as
the king is on d2 it is very unlikely
so Bishop to e6 would further control of
the C 4 square but also a bishop to f7
followed by Bishop captures and h5 might
be an idea just you know it's a nice
bone why not win it rook to h1 a nice
premature defense of the h5 point and
now Bishop to f7 now corona will most
likely go Queen d7 to e8 and then really
win that h5 point so King to e2 and now
comes Queen to d7 and here at Meijer
doesn't allow this he's he very much
enjoys his H five points Oh Queen to a4
and not allowing this idea also or
hoping to trade Queens Khurana isn't
interested he just blocks it with rook
to c6 and c4 is the idea with Queen to
a5 and now comes c4 so what do you do
here why black will of course capture
here even though white is attacking the
e5 pawn twice but there's no time to act
on this rook to a3 defend putting
another defender to the third-ranked and
now rook beat the c7 putting more
pressure here so when this check comes
then the rooks will really put a lot of
pressure along the C file King to d2 now
the King also joins the defense of the
bishop here and now comes Luke the c5
attacking the Queen Queen to a 8 finally
getting that very nice square and now
rook the c8 and here my played rook to
a7 hoping for captures captures but this
doesn't really go anyway any it doesn't
really do anything for Caruana
he's main advantage in this position is
the attack that he currently is leading
so Queen to b5 and here you can see that
Mars Queen doesn't really have a lot of
squares the only square available for
myers queen is going to be 7 but here it
doesn't work because after Queen b7 just
captures captures and here
is enough for black to win now the
problem is after rook captures here and
rook captures here you don't really have
a good way of playing this if pawn
captures let's say then rook the rook
see to check elites the checkmate
captures here and after this the bond
guards to the III square it's checkmate
so this is not possible so Myra decided
against the Queen to b7 and he actually
played Queen captures rook on c8 and now
you can see that well black wins the
Queen but white wins the rook and the
bishop on f7 here so it is some
compensation but it's hardly enough we
have King to g8 by car one the strongest
move you can see that the rook doesn't
really have all that many squares and
the problem is if rook to e7 or rook to
e7 black's idea is the same just Queen
c5 covers a seven covers east 7 and
covers the f2 pawn so after after
grabbing the f2 pawn all of all of
White's pawns are gone and it would be a
very clean victory for black so after
King g8 we have rook captures King
captures and now comes d4 hoping to
close off the the C file but it's only a
temporary relief Bishop captures and now
comes King to f7 getting out of check
rook to d1
and now comes c3 and again if you
capture just Queen c5 with a double
attack here and here again if if DF 2
point falls then all the points fall and
it's over so after the C 3 checkmark
played King to e1 but now comes the
Queen to beat you and it was in this
position animal 51 that Gehrig Mayer
resigned the game and an excellent
victory for Fabiana Caruana in the
penultimate round of the Greinke chest
classic he resigned there is no way to
protect this point and after this point
falls the the past C point will just be
too strong
after you do anything just screen
captures now let's say you can attack
the Queen but Queen d2 check King moves
now can push the pawn and pretty much
anything you do doesn't really matter
you will just Queen the pawn and after
well this is straight it off it's Queen
against the bishop of course an easy
game for black
so after Queen to be - that's game
Corona winsome but we still need to show
the reason why I
decided to show this game after in this
position Khurana played rook to d8 I
mentioned it was a mistake and it really
allowed Maier to really grab a hold of
this game both of them seem to have
missed it I haven't seen an interview
with either of them after the game if
there is I will find it and put a link
to it in the description below but here
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute best move for Maier
here mark played rook to d1 but maybe
there's a better move here so I'll give
you a couple of seconds you know feel
free to do it it's really an amazing
idea for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are worthy and
you are able to lift the rook all the
way and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
the idea is rook captures on g6 and this
is what Khurana missed when he played
this move and basically when he played
rook to a sex he did the defended the b6
properly but this idea really you know
loses any any harmony between the black
rooks and it allows this rook to g6 idea
now you have to capture it otherwise you
allow rook a to g1 and then it's just
over so after you capture it the point
is Knight captures on f4 check and now
you have two options you can either
capture it or run away if you capture it
it's lost immediately Rose you want King
here and you will just win the Queen
captures captures and captures even even
after Luke Jake you can even give up the
bishop after King captures Queen f6 just
wins the game
as you will win the bishop and then you
will win all the pawns you can just
start pushing the pawns and there's not
much black can do if black defends with
row g6 then it's Queen h8 checkmate the
pawn car is the g5 square so after this
King g6 Knight captures an f4 check you
can't capture the knight what you can do
is run away with the king you can't go
here because if you go here then Knight
captures here attack the Queen and the
bishop Knight captures Bishop rook comes
to g1 and then black again falls apart
the only good way for black to defend
this scheme to f7 to actually defend the
the bishop way to the King but now comes
a different idea just
rook g1 with threats of rook captures
and g7 King captures and then Knight
captures an e6 with check wins the Queen
so that's the plan you have to play
Bishop to f6
and now comes Knight captures King
captures and now Queen b5 first a nice
move to activate the Queen the Queen
wants to come to see for the rook is
under attack rook to e8 and now f4 again
if you capture then Ruby g6 will be very
strong just attacking the pin piece and
if you play any other move let's say
King is 7 then you get Ruby g6 rook a
fate and the now comes the Queen to c4
finally the idea is pawn captures pawn
and after Bishop captures the Queen can
come to the e6 square not a lot of ways
you can prevent this here after let's
say rook f7 you will get pawn captures
now you can't capture with the bishop
because Queen checks and wins the bishop
so Bishop has to go back now comes the
Queen here with check King to f8 and now
let's say f4 and the whites position is
just amazing it's very hard to believe
that karana would be able to defend this
position even though he's up the
exchange for the moment but what just
has so many excellent ideas you can you
can win this point you can win this
point you can just start pushing your
points you can go Queen g4 rook g8 it's
just a extremely beautiful position for
white and it's really a shame that Meier
didn't find rook captures on g6 because
we could be covering it we could be
covering this game instead of that one
but it's just an amazing move so it's
really really just a shame after this
rook to d8 that myers spidey-sense
didn't start tingling and he missed this
rook captures on g6 idea well yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
tomorrow most likely didn't especially
after he found this rook at first on g6
after the game but that's just you know
it you know things happen and we just
have to enjoy it whatever happens I
would like to thank Stephen Porter
Charles cotton Miguel Martinez choppa
and barring a murder for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
this says these are the standings after
the penultimate round Carlsen still in
first place with six and a half and
Caruana with five and a half in second
place and Corona is the only one who can
catch up to Magnus but that means that
Corona has to win a game in the final
round Carson has to lose a game in the
final round across and faces maxime
beaugeois graphic as the white pieces
and corona also has the white pieces
against Lebanon Oregon so it's going to
be crazy if cross on
and Khurana wins we will be having a
playoff which is probably what everyone
wants but it's you know both of them
having the white pieces it's it's not
not the greatest of chances that this
will be the outcome but you know it's
just things happen it just might happen
and we're gonna get more chess to enjoy
so once again I do hope you enjoyed it
and yeah I have an excellent rest of
your day and I will see you soon